oh
my god yeah
[Music]
i'm ciel i'm here with ben baller to
talk about some jewelry gq on the rocks
thank you for being here come on
anything for you especially when it
comes to jewelry you know this is like
yes
we need we need you to preach so yo
let's talk about some jewelry yes
[Music]
i'm gonna go first because i know yours
is better i brought in some vintage
jewelries this is actually a chrome
hearts collab that 21 did yeah we had a
whole line that's a big flex i know
about cars like 30 years you know what i
mean right when they did it i was like
okay they bring it back and it's like
you don't ever see k-pop or koreans
dictate fashion but like in that era
when i went to go visit them they
commanded and dictated fashion and these
are what i wore for my first solo music
video was that the gzp yes it's that
video so i brought in this
i got these done in japan because there
was no one you weren't there in korea
first of all there was no one in korea
that did grills back then
so i had to go to japan and get these
done yeah i haven't put these on since
back then i bet they don't fit because
you know your teeth shift even after
does it yeah they shift if they do fit
they're gonna it's gonna be tight damn
okay that's a wrap i can't wear it
anymore anyways
[Music]
okay let's let's start off like
small so two years ago i did my third
official collaboration with takashi
murakami for complex con we decided to
do something fun we made uh six pieces
three black diamond murakami flowers and
then we did three alternate rainbow
murakami flowers they were 50 grand each
they went on sale at 12 o'clock by 1201
all six were sold out where was i i
don't know
for the invite
hey sap rocky hey you [ __ ] did you
really not hold me one yeah like what
the [ __ ] and then like kid cudi somehow
some way he got both of each ones and
then uh how did he get it i don't know
and then we waited till five o'clock to
where me and murakami were doing our
walkthrough of the show
and i brought out this thing and it's
called the flawless flower
and it is all vvs1 which is pretty much
the highest quality that you can buy as
far as parcels and stuff so this is vvs1
d color this is the best of the best and
on top of that it spins the funny thing
is this is an artist proof because the
collection's already sold out meaning
this is my personal piece for the store
so that i can pass down to my kids or
who knows
down to ceo
so yeah it was so quick the prince of
korea he ended up buying um the the one
of one there was only one it was 100
grand it was anonymous i didn't know
until later and that was kind of you
know just what it is i'm very happy that
a korean person bought it
so i collect vintage chanel jewelries
and these are from the 90s
i think this is like the year i was born
91 this one and this one did you ever
wear any of this in front of carl
lagerfeld i think i did nice yeah
do you remember your glasses you had
when we were in new york yeah you're
wearing the original chanel circle
glasses yeah you only paid like a couple
thousand for it whatever i've seen
people pay 15 20 grand to them now what
yeah it's crazy vintage chanel's insane
i remember that day we met pharrell he
wanted yours i exactly is like he's like
texting me where did you get those and i
was like i've got the last one and he i
think he went on and found another one a
lot of money for them
that's a big flex too because you know
skateboard piece he knows this janelle
yeah
uh my favorite would probably be this
right here this one yes because i would
wear that that right there already
enhances my entire office yeah
swag
i could throw that on and people will be
like
if you know you know you know so that's
just it's definitely my favorite for me
ciao's always got she has the freshest
style enough about my pieces i want to
go into
your
crazy pieces we need to talk about this
[Music]
so this was my first custom
fu
i'm rich now i made it i'm a jeweler
like we were the first independent brand
to hit a quarter billion dollars so we
all had crazy pieces and there is a
thing called the magic trade show every
year in vegas that's where everyone goes
and i was like yo 2007 dog is vegas like
i'm about to come really clowning so i
made this state of california because
everyone from all over the world comes
so you know this is like 16 pounds 330
carats this is the state of california
there is a 3.23 carat for la you know
the area kill for las 323 and there is
almost crazy 92 carats of ice blue
diamonds for the pacific ocean these are
all invisible set these are all canary
diamonds princess cut it was just more
like let me wrap where i'm from and i
remember kobe saw it he's like
and i remember snoop saw soups like yo
give me that chain
and it was funny you know this will
actually cut the circulation off your
neck that's why i wear if you ever see
old pictures of me from that era i had a
small little like washcloth on my neck
but i have to take advil when i or
tylenol when i oh my god
so last but not least this piece is my
ultimate masterpiece to date right now
it is the greatest piece i've ever made
it is an official entry in takashi
murakami's art archive it is for kid
cudi's birthday this is the kiki with a
murakami skalmer kami flower chain not
only is this a flower that no one's ever
seen before was debuted at complex con
these little flowers here they spin
you know this is a 680 thousand dollar
piece but you can't buy it because i
don't think if you offered cuddy a
million know he would why would he sell
it his favorite piece this was like
three or four different styles i had to
source these pink sapphires on the kiki
head from australia i have amethyst
coral i have blue sapphires i have
emeralds on here i have so many
different i have chocolate diamonds on
here i have pink diamonds on here i have
grade a a black diamonds even on the
enamel it's not machine done this is
hand done and this thing took me six and
a half months to make and that's with 11
korean diamond setters and these guys
have traditions the hand making is a big
deal because you know we made it with
hand we didn't use the machine you know
so it means something to me my most
proud moment was hallmarking my name
next to takashi murakami's name it's a
pretty big deal
them i was so into like listening to
your story right now i'm just passionate
about it no i am it's so crazy it's
really detailed i mean even in eight
years like how much my life has changed
there's so much competition there's a
million dollars in the world
if i don't separate myself
further and further yeah then i'm going
to get buried in with everyone else
right did you see jeremy scott's grills
i made for the met galloway yeah oh my
god that was crazy it looks like the
crown jewels drop in the pictures he has
emeralds and rubies and it's literally
probably my most craziest grill ever yes
i have an album coming out october i
know so after this
because you weren't there in korea no i
know i know i know i know now this time
you need to make me a custom piece
what would be the perfect one
i don't know what's the name of the
album alpha
alpha so it's got to be bossy yeah
always
you have kind of everything you have
white gold you have yellow gold like
what do you want to do do you want to do
rose you want to do white do you want
yellow on blue diamonds
and yellow gold 22 karat
so fresh yes oh my god that is the alpha
vibe 22 karat yellow gold
blue diamonds
then bought the chain you know i got ccl
don't worry
thank you ben you're welcome for your
time and i don't know just everything
this is crazy thank you for watching
check out my album alpha